ce soir
bon ça va pas
la mignonne avant je te plaît c'est quoi
ce n'est ni connu ce cas
ça se tape
bon il rentre et la balade alors
maintenant tu vas au mois six mois avant
six mois chacun petit ou pas sa 306 pas
cher pas cher on fait tous des noms qui
sont en fait non
à une partie
s'arrête au charbon jeu s'arrête pour
vous ça s'arrête
oui ce qu'on veut mais aussi livres
alors
ça va sûrement narcisse
il ya longtemps que tu fais ça
14 ans
ça marche bien mécontente
entente nom fait référence aussi
voudrait faire pardon tu veux faire des
patrouilles dans une banque on peut non
plus dans sa main
qu'est-ce qui t'aurait plus sinon
effectivement rêve plus
la td et aurait fait quoi toi pu faire
une émission arrière garde amanda lear
qui a fait de la télé rien de brillant
une émission de cuisine
passez maïté tu ferais bien cargo c'est
une idée ça c'est une grande idée ça dit
j'aimerais faire exister ça serait drôle
oui ils ont jamais pensé tu sais quoi
ils sont un peu rétrograde de la police
peut-être que sur le câble on aura des
émissions de cuisine présenté par des
paresseux palestine et ses shows des
fois au québec
oui si c'est pas mais tu es toujours été
là
alors par mois
oui 6 non et non
martyrs comment tu t'appelles catherine
joly martial installé à bientôt le nom à
20 h
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
1h10 tube abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux